what's up party people
welcome to honest trailer commentaries
the show where we talk about our show on
its trailers which is the show where we
talk about other people's shows and
movies thanks for being here
hopefully you watch the honest trailer
for spider-man into the spider-verse and
now you're hanging here with us watching
honest trailer commentaries if you
haven't watched it yet hit pause real
quick and go watch it come back and see
us or just you've special brave souls
that only watch this show god bless you
and you do you we are going to talk over
it absolutely gonna talk over it and
video starts now I'm Joe lon Harris
dannielle Radford both joined me in
writing this this this thing this epic
sort of monster Spencer still being a
dad Dan off traveling we wish you the
best buddy we'll see you in about a week
yes so spider-man into the spider purrs
let's talk movie and then maybe after
the trailer we can talk about just the
weird monster that this I'm really glad
that that we came up with like a bit
like a gimmick for this one instead of
just doing it straight because this
movie is good yes it would be hard to
just write a lot of jokes about yet
there's not a lot just I feel like we it
gets real nitpicky when a movie is this
good right yeah and we're not really
into nitpicking yes I looked over my
notes and a lot of it was like I mean
technically that's true but it come on
it's good yeah and this isn't really
like a nitpicky show like yeah there's
stuff you can sort of like poke at but
like another is another Internet show
that maybe you're thinking about I don't
know if you if you really want to get
the nitty gritty there are plenty of
options for you uh this this is honest
trailers and we're about the funny yeah
and well and we're about the honest and
as cuz when I when I first came in and I
wrote my first drafts or Spencer I was
like we're roasting let's let's roast
and I would just like for a good movies
I think my person was like Aladdin
and I was just like this garbage bread
just run like I was writing for a roast
battle yeah and Spencer was like no this
is a honest honest honest not just like
funny jokes yeah I love this movie I am
a Lubeck own own me I used to work in
international distribution and Warner
Brothers and part of my job was every
morning I would update they had a giant
spreadsheet and every tab of the
spreadsheet was every month of the year
for the next 15 years of movies and and
when they were releasing in every
country in the world and every day that
would change and every day my job in the
morning was to go in and make those
updates in that spreadsheet Wow
and so for years I looked at untitled
animated spider-man movie on Sony's
really stalking to move around but I was
always like what did he what is this you
know like because I think even at the
time like amazing spider-man 2 and just
come out and I was like you have a
spider-man yeah I don't what I don't
understand what this is and then there
was the MCU and and Sony but you know
the whole agreement happened and I was
still like what what is this spider-man
cartoon like it seems dumb and even when
I heard it announced I was like I will
get it I'm not sold the howdy Eddie
because I've just been trained now by
the MCU I guess yeah well it's it's
weird that we fell into it seems like
animation would be such a natural medium
for comic-book adaptations already
drawings it sounds like we have those
drawings to life and I remember seeing
Batman mask of the phantasm in theaters
which was like the right age group for
Meighan industries it's so good but if
you don't see Batman is broy it's the
universe that streaming platform they
have now please do watch it it's great
and ever since then I feel like I've
been sort of keyed into when are we
gonna get some theatrical animated
superhero films and I don't have just
developed in this other way and it
became weird for people why I think
there are a lot of movies that you can
say or maybe the start of it but we
definitely got into a place where we
wanted our superhero movies to be taken
seriously as art darn it and in the u.s.
at least cartoons or an animated is
still very much thought of as a key
Media yeah unlike in obviously Japan and
other places and so what's going on in
Japan oh oh no so that was it I was
basically done just you know we we
wanted something that was more you know
not necessarily adult but at least
something that was pg-13 and it was
thought at the time that you couldn't
really do that even though you did have
so many of these amazing Batman animated
movies yeah the DC animated movies like
the direct you know video and now
streaming it they're great a lot of them
are really great so it does seem like
there's been an awareness in general
like there is an audience for cool aimed
at teens and adults animated movies with
super airs but hopefully maybe this will
be the yeah the deciding factor but then
it just blows my mind that and I guess
shade intended to Sony because amazing
spider-man 2 isn't great and the first
amazing spider-man isn't great and
Venom's fine but like this is like I'm
shocked that a studio was like this
movie and every step of the way was like
yeah yeah do it because I mean this
movies kind of art like I don't yeah we
say it in the trailer but it's it's it's
a work of art it's a visual work of art
there are so many ways that could have
gone wrong yeah I and we've seen them in
live-action yeah and it's even harder in
animation and you know when you get a
good team together then that's when you
make this happen and I love online with
all of them are constantly beating each
other up they're sharing things from
every department this is a team that
definitely knows that this is a team
effort it's not just about Lord and
Miller it's about you know it's not just
about Peter Ramsey it's about everyone
oh by the way Peter Ramsey does not have
a blue checkmark yet okay weird that's
weird you know what I don't know either
neither do I so it's clearly a problem
with the mark Steve Ramsey here we're
justice for Joe star you know it doesn't
bother me that I don't have a blue
checkmark most of the time until I go to
somebody's account who's got like 200
followers and they have one I don't know
why they bother me hang on it bothers me
I'm more important than this person I'm
just looking for things to fill the void
and the blue checkmarks gonna do it just
anything just tell me you like me tell
me I'm valid tell me I just needed this
I love this movie it's it's fun it's
dramatic it hits the the theme of Spider
Man yeah I think that were hard going in
I sort of expected because you know I
had pretty good buzz when I saw and
Lorne Miller I figured okay this will be
a cool
spider-man adventure I like the idea of
having all the different Spider Man in
it but what I did not expect and what I
think is really what takes it to that
next level is it's just it's a really
good coming-of-age story about Miles
Morales like yes it's one of the best
superhero origin movies I can think of
because it really invests you in this
guy and gives you his perspective on
being spider-man yeah and I did not see
that it takes those standard beats that
everybody does for the origin but just
hits them better and from different
angles and yeah I'd love to I mean he
feels real and three tonight
like three dimensional in a way that a
lot of live action superhero
protagonists don't even until their
second or third movie you know like yeah
Doctor Strange gets introduced and we're
all like for that first movie like okay
but then when you see him in your video
we're like okay they finally got it'll
do yeah that's who he is this feels like
they got Miles immediately like there's
Novarum a moment where you don't know
who this kid is
yeah no it's fantastic let's uh let's
watch the tree
[Music]
for years Sony has tried to launch a
spider-verse to call its own some have
been good
some have been bad some have been venom
and some never even started swinging now
they're back with an all-new strategy
saying get and doing all the spider
stuff at once spider-man into the spider
verse strap it with this fresh take on
your favorite neighborhood superhero
that's probably one of the best movies
of 2018 but it's got a lot of spiders in
it he's a work art man
maybe I'll just write the clock on this
one by pushing around the buttons in my
booth what's this one do this you had
total credit to you as a as a writer
just now you had a really elaborate
explanation there were like different
buttons and I think he spilled coffee on
as a super collider and I was like it's
really funny that Joe invested in the
reality of epic voice guy in his booth
another important to me I figured it was
not gonna make it into the video trailer
yeah but I am glad it was there yeah
yeah the original version of this was um
yeah he was like uh I guess I'll just
sit and play with my particle collider
yeah isn't like that
yeah and he's like and then yeah went on
forever and it was like oh that's not a
good Sam it was good ten seconds there
was a lot so I wrote this one okay so
this one is my I guess my big swing
without without dad here after I wrote
it I was like I have no idea that this
is good or not and so I did send this
some dispenser and was like hey what do
you have a minute and he wrote back and
he was like looks good I don't know if
that was just kind of like I haven't
slept in eight days stop sending me
things but he was like how about his
cool Collider he just spills coffee on
his sound board and I was like good note
yeah and then so it went from particle
- oh no coffee is spilling and it was
still just like too much and then here's
why I think this team works is because
we have great people like you guys
coming in and just being like you didn't
think about this you didn't think about
this here's a joke in and then you have
me who's like what if there's a particle
collider
and then you have Dan who is like dance
the glue here that's no news to anyone
while you screen junkies but Dan is
always the guy who's and that that's why
he gets the the reputation for being
grumpy or being commonly or whatever cuz
he's always the guy who's like I don't
know dude which I need I need like I
need that we're just talking about how
the route of the show isn't who can make
the best snap against the movie it's
honest yeah and that is Dan keeps us
honest laughs uh you and I Daniel - all
of us at this table
we're goofballs who would do anything to
make the joke sell I just want to come
up with the best joke yeah and Dan's the
guy who's like even if it won't make the
joke funnier it's gotta be it's gotta be
that was word-for-word his pitch he was
like I don't know what if he was just
like frustrated about the movie he just
wanted to run out of time but putting
pushing buttons in his booth I was like
perfect that's that's yeah so yeah
before we get into premise I just want
to also point out I love this trailer if
nothing else then for these portals
opening right Kevin our editor did an
amazing job with them JT I don't know if
you can just like frame by frame back
through these but there's all these big
honest trailer moments yeah Alan Raptor
you saw Felicia Day pop in just like
Tyler Durden frame-by-frame style
yeah they outdid themselves with
everything that pops up in these portals
and I love them yeah these are these are
all like random little honest trailer
Easter Egg yeah
the Raptors in there yeah and no it's
great all right let's keep going
whoa I don't think I'm in my recording
booth anymore who are you
I'm epic geek girl the voice of honest
trailers from an alternate dimension
just sunny upbeat and emotionally
healthy
and and what that's all the explanation
the movie gave want to team up for this
one heck yeah Suda for a fresh new take
on the spider-man franchise that
combines jaw-dropping camerawork and
fever dream visuals with a multicultural
hip-hop fueled New York that proves Sony
product placement is the one constant in
the multiverse to create a bold breaking
superhero story with the meta of
Deadpool and Lego Batman Senator comic
oh what's Comic Con the heart of
Superman and the visual style of pix
actually this movie doesn't look
anything like the animation we've gotten
used to does every animated character in
your reality do the eyebrows thing - yep
so I see a lot of people complain about
anime and animation out of Japan like oh
it all just kind of like looks the same
we definitely have a western style of
animation and it's getting old yeah they
call this DreamWorks face but you could
clearly see that the smirking eyebrow
app thing is not just read yeah also sad
note in any picture of me doing stand-up
I will be making DreamWorks you're a
b-movie there was a blog post that sort
of like cycle I think of like a like a
body language expert wrote it and it was
like why do we want to see all animated
characters make DreamWorks face I wish I
had it it's really interesting it's like
it implies like confidence but things
are getting crazy it's like and it's
like if you want to balance both of
those emotions in one face it's like
they're absolutely before I even
realized that I was doing a DreamWorks
face this is absolutely what my stand-up
headshot oh yeah it was me wearing a
sports coat and a an inert shirt going
hmm like because I'm supposed to be here
I'm a good comedian but I'll say you
don't know it's good
I think I was standing from like a
woman's bathroom door you walked out
there cuz you want again this is why I
another reason I love this movie so much
is because um you know Disney I don't
think did look their stuff looks
beautiful but I don't think they did
themselves any favor favors when they're
like everything has to look like it can
fit into the Disney infinity game so
everything's gonna have similar design
qualities because it all needs to unify
there's different stuff Pixar sameness
like the a lot of Pixar character
designs look the same and then now
Disney has adopted like yes wreck-it
Ralph Disney is like we're gonna do
Pixar - yeah so now it's like all of
Disney has kind of yeah DreamWorks stuff
ain't that different looking so it's
yeah and that's like we spent three
fewer months on this guy's cam that's
why I love spider-verse so much it just
we don't get stuff like this this often
I felt like I was spoiled I really
honestly ever cuz even I've been
watching that Netflix animated anthology
love death in that because that is like
all different styles of animation
they're trying to do sort of grabbing
things but it still feels very
derivative a lot of the time like a lot
of those episodes it's like oh I get
what kind of animation this is and like
yep that's that whereas this feels like
no other animated thing I've ever seen
yeah just the use of colors obviously
and I've seen other things that have
used the comic panels but not in the way
that this has where it is ingest those
shots where it's a comic panel it's also
little tiny details in the background
where you will see that something looks
like the way old four-color printing
used to look in certain elements behind
it so just trippy it's like a it's like
a head movie like in the 60s and 70s
they used to have had movies which are
like do a bunch of psychedelic drugs
that go this way that I'm recommending
that's where young viewers what if I I
mean you could but like this is that
kind of movie where it would be like
it's a crazy onslaught it's like a
visual experience yes no absolutely
let's keep God yep
this booth is getting kind of crowded
who are you three
I'm the epic dungeon master a far
traveler from a distant realm who earns
his keep being critical about movies yes
your love was época la mujer telenovela
your regular soul pacion I lost honest
Ryan I'm Australian how's that work
continue this quest pause let's see here
what were these originally supposed to
be Australian boys guy was supposed to
be it was gonna be a silent movie oh
right yeah oh my god they were just like
pop-up screens with like blinky music21
yeah then you guys actually had a really
nice sort of push back against that idea
which I appreciate it which was like
next to the telenovela voice that's just
a lot of reading - yeah yeah which made
total sense so we reached out to to
Sunday movies who is one of the funniest
just just it's really annoying because I
as professional comedians who work
really hard to like try to be funny and
like really craft jokes and what I'm
gonna do onstage mr. sunny movies just
says anything and it's just there's just
something about not just in a accent
like I'm a dumb American delivery is
dryness is so effortlessly funny that it
listening to him because today in the
room we were playing all of the sound
clips over nowhere to find the right the
rat takes and I just I love that we
forced an Australian got to say all the
things Americans think Australian people
it was it was like Farrar just a joke
for our benefit on one level because
he's just over there like good guy yeah
I was like hey I'm sorry what this feels
like a little like Dundee face it was
like nah man let's go for ya and I'll
just also as a side note he had like a
medical thing come up during all this I
think he's been talking about a little
bit on Twitter and like today he was
because we did a few rewrites because in
the room also initially with this
character
we were like wouldn't it be funny if all
the other characters had these big huge
introductions introduced in the dag and
then he was just like I'm Dave I'm
Australian and like on paper it was
really funny and in the room is really
funny but then in practice he almost got
stepped on because everyone else was big
and up and he's like I'm Dave and then
just the video just like keeps cranking
and it he kind of got buried so we did a
bunch of rewrites for him and it was he
had this medical thing come up and we're
like okay we get it and so we reworked
it with what he had already recorded and
then today like when he's supposed to be
recovering it was like hey I was gonna
do it yesterday but I collapsed with a
fever so speaking since we're talking
about some of the people we also had for
the tone is the awesome and amazingly
funny Vanessa griten who knows Jamie
fights yeah who was amazing and has
wonderful blue hair and it's obviously
super funny and nailed back completely
yes yes and the pronunciation yeah I and
then we also had Matt Mercer from a from
critical role was also kind enough to
jump in we premiered this at WonderCon
on Friday and it was funny when normal
just jokes for everyone landed and then
very specific critical jokes that I
wrote because I'm a critical role and
like you hear like 20 people in the
audience go but yeah and of course
Felicia Day is our epic the kooky girl
they were really kind enough to jump in
and do this because which I was really
excited about because when I saw this
movie I was like I think the only take
on doing spider-verse is if we have a
bunch of alternate dimension voice
people come in and I want two of them to
be Matt Mercer and Felicia Day so I was
super pumped that they were able to do
this very very excited thank you guys
very much let's keep going
mark you're Peters because there's an
all-new spider-man on the block Miles
Morales he's a relatable sweet nerdy
high school kid that was bitten by a
radioactive spider through evil they see
wait how is he all new this spot a man
likes so while we were working on this
we all had that song stuck in our how do
you not get that specifically that
version where you cannot hear and so
periodically I would start singing it
and Joe would be like dad
damn it Radford and once one time over
the weekend I said to me yeah she's a
horrible friend everyone I just want to
know how Myles sings them yeah this was
a this one too because so this is
another thing sort of Dana and I talked
about with the approach on this trailer
is we did Deadpool one with Ryan
Reynolds and it was it was a pretty good
balance of meta and talking about the
movie the Deadpool 2 trailer maybe went
a little too far we're just talking
about honest trailers and we got a lot
of feedback on that and that was kind of
like why aren't you guys talking about
Deadpool to which on when Ian was tough
because there wasn't like a ton to say
about it and yeah you actually think we
did we ended up doing what we did for
Deadpool too because it was like well
how do we not just reiterate what I said
about that for one and so that was one
thing we really wanted to make sure we
got here was like let's make sure we get
everything we want to say and despite
her voice and like work it into the
funny gags I think we did a pretty good
job yeah despite all the gimmickry of
like all the voices or whatever like it
very much still is about the movie yeah
even though even little lines like
that's the only explanation airing again
for why you're an alternate being it's
like that's all the movie did let's go
right
yeah yeah so yeah I think we did a
better job balancing on this one but you
shall be the judge
post Malone let's go but you won't want
to walk a mile in his loose-fitting
shoes because this spider guy doesn't
just have one coming-of-age problem he's
got all of them from dealing with his
demanding dad finding his artistic voice
to fitting in and a new school a month
in the end the 1i motor broke evil and
puberty it's a puberty thing I don't
know why I said that
crikey just so much beauty please stop
sticking but miles isn't alone on his
spider quest because plenty of spider
folk are joining his party from the hot
bod version to the dad bod version a
Nicholas Cage
I see no pub and a and me small
sometimes I let mattress burn down to my
fingertips just to feel something
anything
John Mulaney playing himself I just
watched my hands that's why they're wet
it's one that's so and am amazed she's
not licensed by Funimation together
they'll battle all-new takes on classic
spider bad guys like the chaotic neutral
and completely terrifying Prowler and
the sexy cat lady version of Doc Ock all
led by the kingpin a tragic villain
mourning the loss of his wife his son
and his neck hey don't take my
punchlines in my own booth sorry Mike
sorry this is a mess out of the movie
keep all those manageable so take
goodbyes I didn't want to talk a little
bit about the villain yes this was this
was the one thing I had watching the
movie where I was like that's honest
trailer a bowl it's weird that in the
animated spider-man they're using all of
the human regular guy looking villains
kingpins just a man in a suit tombstones
just a grey man with some guns this is
your chance animated they're using the
stereo in the live-action well the
fishbowl magic head guy he's in the
live-action line
he's just a man in a suit put him in the
live-action one you could do my Spencer
like okay okay I will say on the villain
Oh a prowler is actually scary as hell
yeah and in this now we can also talk
about uncle Aaron being a very bad uncle
oh yeah I love uncle Aaron but like
maybe don't take your favorite nephew
the kid you kind of look after as your
son to go do graffiti at the place where
you do crimes the same place where you
do it's also like all the villains in
this movie is like kingpin obviously
he's so fixated on getting his family
back he's not thinking about any
consequences single minded it's part of
the character I can go with that but all
the other villains at some point should
be like we all live in New York do we
want to like blow it I like they're
they're willing to destroy the city to
get kingpins wife back I don't
understand my thought is like I think
Doc Ock sort of jumps on him a few times
about it like it's not quite ready and
it's unstable and this yeah and so they
they have their they're uneasy thing
Stone is all in for this plan it's like
what how does benefit from this some of
them I just I sort of go they don't need
to know you know they're like the the
goons on the street the street lights
are turning into street lights from 18
dimensions you'd be like this seems
weird well my guess is is you know we
know the kingpin will kill folks if they
don't do what he wants so maybe they're
very blond yeah maybe I maybe I just
ride it out and hope that this doesn't
collapse the universe better it's a
bullet in the head right now he did give
me this cool purple ghost suit that's
true yeah that makes I think my favorite
movie fully noise in a while just the
weird noise and music that accompanies
prowler yes that weird it's almost like
the annihilation trailer noise like it's
just so cool to to see a movie take a
villain who's like a not very exciting
villain and make them really cool yeah
that doesn't happen very easily it's the
opposite we use they use the Green
Goblin the ultimate version of Green
Goblin
mutate about super fun goblin yeah super
fun yeah and I also love that like this
movie at no point ever feels the need to
stop and be like this green Goblin's
different from the Defoe guy it's like
no you just you don't even they don't
even do a dramatic introduction for him
I don't think mouth drops in a thing and
you see from his point of view in the
distance just this giant goblin man
yappin on em already yeah it's great and
the way that they do it visually to let
you know like hey this is how things are
different is when they do which is
probably also product placement but when
they do that difference between you know
the big Coca Cola Times Square stuff and
then it changes into whatever their
generic Coca Cola is you know the
different you know they did the the Nick
Kroll and John Mulaney they change the
name of that hello and that's enough no
that's great yeah I mean I like when
they trust us there's so many over the
years I think we've all gotten to the
point where we want to see depictions of
these comic book worlds as they exist on
the page so like in a Batman comic there
isn't only one villain taking over
Gotham at once like there is in the
movie it's like in the movie it's like
this time Joker's the villain and like
he's the villain yeah but in the comics
it's just a world where all of this is
it's like all happening at once and I
think that's what this movie does a
really good job that almost none of the
other superhero movies do which is even
see you weirdly like even for all its
interconnectedness is usually just like
here's our villain this time like one
you know like maybe you do the Captain
Marvel looks like we got ronan and
there's Korath also but like usually not
usually it's like if winter soldiers in
it winter soldiers the bad guy well as
this takes place in the world that feels
like a lived in spider-man world where
there's just yeah like all the
spider-man villas would all be alive at
the same time yeah that's why I was kind
of sad in a black panther when claw dies
yeah I think claw could be a really good
Turk for uh for the MCU just like he
just pops up in places you know like he
could have been such a good just yes the
guy we crap on sort of Samsung I don't
get to see Andy Serkis yeah yeah well
snap and who knows what happens after oh
that's true we go we go back to the 70s
or whatever and he's still around I see
70s Andy Serkis ulysses klaw yeah super
into that buggy you can have that one
that is yours let's continue so take a
leap with a movie that sounded like a
terrible idea when you first heard about
it but ended up being so good we can't
wait for more miles down under
Australian del hombre ranked entrando
second su propio veronica los dos campos
itself by KO dusim waiting for that one
well guys it's been fun but it's time to
wrap up how do you want to do this story
well Peter Pienaar plucked a pack of
Peter Parker's sweaty woman Jon Hamm my
hero academia cage against the Michigan
and hey and purposive our ally book hero
six you know you guys could always stay
we could be an epic voice family sorry
Mike kangaroos do box of a musketeer
more Luca podemos estar juntos you think
okay aggressor let me put up your copy
until we meet again my friend is it
Tuesday yet peace if we stay here our
atoms will explode so later nerd
bye Felicia oh man come back you because
I'm not watching the Jared Leto Morbius
movie by myself did you see that photo
of him today by the way sucking from a
bag like that would normally contain
blood you do this Jared oh he does I bet
he's sending them to his co-stars mm-hmm
she's really getting into character yeah
that's that's the trailer there it is
personally yeah there are some some of
the best starring tsar the ones where
our backs are against a wall we haven't
thought of anything else and someone
says something very stupid yeah that's
true and those are the and that's the
Peter Parker picked a pic of yes where
that came from
literally I said the stupidest thing I
could think of which was yes as your
Diner Chris Pine and that's where Peter
Pienaar pleasure to perform you guys go
I think it was originally the very first
draft where it was nice Peter which was
a epigraph yeah yeah we also we're gonna
do you versus the spider-man she cannot
- we realize we use that joke for for
predator predator yeah yep yep I have
four jokes in me really makes me feel
badly about myself because I didn't
realize how many times I pitched pull
from the stands over Anna Maria on my
watch we've used man it feels twice so
I'm like I'm glad we caught it because I
have a hard time keeping up ever as long
as we're speaking in praise of Dan this
is why it's really helpful to have him
Rock because he remembers a lot more
honest trailers jokes than I do yes so
he's the guy that often is like now
we've done that yes I am a little too
much of a stoner to not be like you
idiot
yeah you've used that before that was
last week yeah you [ __ ] you dumb dumb
[ __ ] what else you got yeah we got yeah
okay yeah I think we've got just some
stuff like that let's run him
storing Silkk the Shocker
which was our favorite versus the
spider-man have you not to worry about
nicepeter Teenage Mutant Ninja scene
girl great gay pins in one year what a
world full metal arachnid spider Hemet
and that'll do pick swingers the
spinister six so we had the the fortune
of premiering this one at WonderCon on
friday which was very nerve-wracking
because it's always so fun to unveil a
thing in front of a thousand people we
like had barely gotten a chance to watch
it so excited we had all the alts in in
though in the run that they saw and
we've literally dan and i were just like
okay biggest laugh bug hero six check
biggest laugh I would watch 500 miles
check cuz so if the Shocker was probably
just for us thinking no chance this gets
it because it was my favorite late 90s
Dirty South people the more No Limit
look Ben sir is gone long and if you
want to make some no limit jokes
finally my master peeve is you make
those jokes eh uh I want to say at least
are we not saying to not now yes please
at least every draft we each throw in
about three jokes that are just to make
everyone else laugh and go you really
thought this was going to get it yeah Oh
spider-ham it was just for me because
dashiell hammett is the father of modern
war and oh that cat just got silence and
it's not the ham the hand is the hand
yeah bug hero 6 what are you saying
fine but yeah that's that's the trailer
Kevin Amin Randy and Max song who's the
editor on honest game trailers all came
in on this one and just like knocked it
out of the park yeah
frenetic visually as you can tell yeah
you guys were drops um I don't know if
all of those guys are on Twitter if you
followed them so just like on the tweet
for this honest trailer like show those
dude some love because yeah especially
leading up to WonderCon this had to get
done earlier we had a whole bunch of
other deadlines to hit and we just piled
you know like a little kid dumps all
dirt and Legos out in the middle of the
room it just spreads them like that's
what we did with assignments for them in
the last week they absolutely nailed it
so thank you to y'all yeah this was
great
Felicia Day of course check out her her
comedy sci-fi podcasts a voyage to the
stars and of course Matt Mercer is the
host of critical role which you should
also watch and I hope you enjoyed all of
my very deep cut critical role
references in the trailer because those
were also just for me I feel like I got
I got some of them Thursday's I got it
I'm sure there's some that I don't get
but but they were wonderful and it's
it's always weird voiceover is like a
weird magical thing to me especially
watching like an actual scene between
multiple characters get put together
because usually no one's in the same
room that is like sometimes they'll show
behind the scenes and they'll show the
actors together and it's that's a lot it
always amazes me to watch these folks
read and know that like when they're
doing a run they're like oh this is how
you would inflect the fourth thing in
this list like that's always yeah and
then although impressive making sure to
give you so many different options
cuz knowing hey like it's a different
joke if I hit this word differently
which logically we
no but then when you're in a booth and
you've got to do it yeah yeah they'd I
just thought that they absolutely nailed
it and that was super super fun and it's
always fun to add to the Canon of the
epic voice guy now he has a bunch of
multiple now there's alternate voice
dimension yes voice dimensions yeah
super fun yeah that's about it you guys
have any um we also uh we also want to
think like we said before mr. Sunday
movies yeah uh movies Vanessa griten
absolutely killed the select I believe
you can find working a good mythical
morning now I think so yeah support them
they try to make things into tacos and
you guys should really like it's just
nice to support an underdog and you
really really should yeah that's that's
it next week is um well I know what this
is I just want to would one of you like
to come up with the tease it's the only
movie I've watched so far for these that
I wanted to punch in the face okay
that's you know what I think that's a
that's a good enough tease to keep the
engine running I kind of liked it it's a
smug smug movie alright well we will see
you right back here next week have a
good week
you
[Music]